sur ce plateau stéphane witkowski
président du conseil de gestion de
l'institut des hautes études de
l'amérique latine à la sorbonne bonjour
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
jahia robot et sonar ou se rend demain
aux états unis va y rencontrer
donald trump concept donald trump est un
fervent soutien du nouveau président
brésilien est ce que cette visite
c'est une suite de ce qui se passe
entre le venezuela et le brésil est ce
que les présidents américains et
brésiliens vont discuter de tout ça oui
certainement c'est un des éléments
d'explication je dirais d'abord qu'il ya
une antipathie personnelle entre les
deux présidents le président brésilien
le président maduro bien évidemment des
divergences idéologiques majeures depuis
l'arrivée du président ball sonar au
brésil et puis bien évidemment que cette
politique d'alignement du brésil sur la
politique nord-américaine de donald
trump et puis ya probablement des
raisons de politique intérieure
brésilienne qui peuvent l'expliquer
alors pour revenir sur ce ce contentieux
je dirais qui s'est aggravée il faut
quand même rappeler que on est quand
même passé d'un processus d'intégration
régionale particulièrement intégré sous
la présidence de malefoy lula et dilma
rousseff ou le venezuela était membre
partie prenante du maître souffle donc
ce marché commun des pays du cône sud
dont le brésil et le venezuela l'uruguay
le paraguay et l'argentine étaient
parties prenantes dont il y avait
vraiment ce grand projet de faire face
en partie pour des raisons d'intégration
régionale face aux roses américain dont
il avait déjà ce premier point
et puis il ya eu une dégradation
progressive d'une part sous la
présidence temer qui a donc succédé à
dilma rousseff qui a effectivement avait
décidé déjà de retirer
de part et d'autre caracas et brasilia
de retirer leurs ambassadeurs respectifs
et là il ya eu une dégradation des
relations accentuée par la fois certain
nombre d'incidents des incidents
militaires la frontière en février 2019
déjà au moment de cette affaire du
couloir humanitaire où on parlait de ce
cette possibilité je dirais une
intervention extérieure organise le l'un
des incidents plus récemment au mois de
décembre lors dans une caserne militaire
où venezuela provoquant un mort
et puis probablement des vagues
d'évacuation une intervention militaire
à l'ambassade du venezuela à brasilia et
jusqu'à cette déclaration de retrait du
personnel et honnête ou quasi
pratiquement à la quasi rupture des
relations diplomatiques on n'y est pas
tout à fait là et on est presque là
justement vous avez évoqué tout ce qui
s'est passé précédemment depuis
pratiquement un an cette dégradation
mais là sur ce qui se passe maintenant
c'est quoi le phénomène déclencheur
phénomène déclencheur c'est d'une part
la visite comme vous l'évoquez du
président rossonero à brazil à aux états
unis donc je pense qu'il ya des gages à
donner de la part de molson arrow
vis-à-vis de la vie de trump et puis
probablement aussi des raisons de
politique intérieure vous savez que dans
le scénario est engagé dans un conflit
intérieur politique et institutionnelle
par rapport au congrès où il ya des
grandes manifestations qui sera prévu
sont prévues au mois de mars 15 mars
qui est il a besoin probablement de
faire vibrer la corde nationaliste
je pense qu'il tint un calcul de court
terme car au fond ni probablement
profondément l'itamaraty l'immense
majorité des diplomates brésiliens ne
sont pas sur cette ligne là et encore
moins l'armée une grande partie de
l'armée qui a une tradition je dirais
une tradition nationale qui n'est pas
conforme à cette décision personnelle
prise par dans le président bernard o
donc là on c'est un geste symbolique 1
la fête de rappeler c'est ces diplomates
après ce stade qu'est ce qui peut se
passer vous parler de rupture totale de
la commande à bâtir en être là puisqu'il
ya 15000 brésilien qui travaille au
venezuela il ya quand même des caisses
en vacances pour d'où le maintien des
consulats sont au même maintenu parce
que pour des raisons évidentes ils
peuvent pas complètement rompre les
relations diplomatiques mais il faut
comprendre que cette ce geste
est en rupture totale avec une vieille
tradition brésilienne de politique
d'intégration régionale rappeler aussi
que rappelez-vous le retrait des
médecins cubains
au brésil le vote du de molson araud
lors du du vote contre la résolution de
l'onu condamnant l'embargo américain
contre contre cuba dont c'est le seul
pays à avoir voté avec les états unis
israël ce qui était une rupture absolue
avec cette vieille tradition brésilienne
d'intégration régionale en rupture avec
je dirais presque un siècle de tradition
diplomatique brésilienne et merci
beaucoup à stéphane ducos qui est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
conseil de gestion de l'institut des
hautes études de l'amérique latine à la
sorbonne
merci